This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人真事。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字就是数字TWO。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》播客中。对1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这么做。请在IHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。埃伦女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hi, it's Gemma, and I'm so excited to share a special bonus episode with you today. It's actually an episode of my other podcast, Marjor, which, which I feel like is such a great companion to the psychology of your 20s. If you haven't listened to mantra before, each week I basically introduce a new mantra, a simple but empowering phrase and then I unpack what it means, what it means to be personally, but also what it means on a collective level. Plus, I share journal prompts, tips, and of course psychological strategies
后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。嗨，我是杰玛，我很高兴今天能与大家分享一集特别的福利节目。实际上，这是我的另一个播客《曼陀罗》的一集，我觉得它与《20多岁的心理学》是非常好的伴侣。如果您以前没有听过《曼陀罗》，我每周基本上会介绍一个新的曼陀罗，一个简单但赋能的短语，然后我会剖析它的含义，它对个人的意义，以及它在集体层面的意义。此外，我还分享了日记提示、技巧，当然还有心理学策略
to help you take each mantra and put it into action in your life. The episode I'm sharing with you today is one of my favorites for the mantra. I am not here to manage other people's emotions. I think this is something we could all incorporate a little bit more into our lives. It's definitely a reminder that I needed. So I'm so excited for you guys to listen to it and to check it out. And if you like what you hear, make sure to follow Mantra on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, or wherever you are listening.
来帮助你将每个曼陀罗付诸生活中的行动。我今天与你们分享这一集是我最喜欢的关于曼陀罗的一集。我来这里不是为了管理别人的情绪。我认为这是我们都可以更多地融入生活的东西。这绝对是我需要的提醒。所以我很高兴你们能收听并查看它。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请务必在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你正在收听的任何地方关注《曼陀罗》。
I'll also include a link to Mantra in the episode notes. you can easily find it. Happy listening. I am so enthralled by this mantra. I am in love with it. It is the one I personally really need it this week. Let me begin by explaining what it may look like to manage other people's emotions. Some of you probably don't need me to tell you. You feel it every day. But just to make it super clear what we're talking about here, I want to give a little bit of a peek behind the curtain, a little bit of a description. Managing other people's emotions It's not feeling bad for someone. It's not having empathy. It's not expressing kindness. It's when we take on the responsibility of regulating someone else's internal state as if it were our own, often at the expense
我也将在分集备注中包含指向《曼陀罗》的链接。你可以轻松找到它。收听愉快。我深深地被这个曼陀罗迷住了。我爱上它了。这是我个人本周非常需要的一个。让我首先解释一下管理别人的情绪可能是什么样子的。你们中的一些人可能不需要我告诉你。你每天都能感受到它。但为了让我们在这里讨论的事情超级清晰，我想稍微窥探一下幕后，做一个小小的描述。管理别人的情绪 这不是为某人感到难过。这不是有同理心。这不是表达善良。这是当我们承担起调节他人内部状态的责任时，就好像它是我们自己的一样，通常是以牺牲
of our own emotions. It's when someone else is sad, angry, disappointed, or even just in a bad mood, and we instinctively adjust our behavior, our mood, our tone, or even our beliefs to soothe or appease them. So it's not just about caring how someone else feels. That's a very great natural human feeling. And it should be promoted. It's basically trying to then control how they feel, believing that if we just say the right thing, if we fix the problem, if we're attentive enough, if we cheer them up, if we kick them calm, then everything is going to be okay. So it's beyond emotional awareness. It's emotional
我们自己的情绪为代价。当别人悲伤、生气、失望，甚至只是心情不好时，我们会本能地调整我们的行为、情绪、语调，甚至是我们的信仰，来安抚或取悦他们。所以这不仅仅是关心别人的感受。这是一种非常伟大的自然人类情感。并且应该被提倡。这基本上是试图控制他们的感受，认为如果我们说正确的话，如果我们解决问题，如果我们足够细心，如果我们让他们振作起来，如果我们让他们保持平静，那么一切都会好起来的。所以这超越了情感意识。这是情感
overcompensating. This looks like a lot of different things. It might look like over-explaining yourself to prevent someone from getting upset. It might feel like walking on eggshells or constantly anticipating how your words or your actions might be misinterpreted. It might mean putting your needs, your truth on hold to avoid setting someone off. It might also. It might also look like, you know, being at an important event for yourself and constantly thinking about how someone else is feeling, constantly monitoring their emotions to make sure they're okay, they're having fun, they're not upset, to the point where you just can't even enjoy yourself anymore. The defining feature here is ownership. You believe often unconsciously that their
过度补偿。这看起来有很多不同的东西。它可能看起来像过度解释自己以防止某人生气。它可能感觉像如履薄冰，或者不断预测你的言论或行为可能被如何误解。它可能意味着将你的需求、你的真相搁置一旁，以避免惹恼某人。它也可能。它也可能看起来像，你知道的，在你自己的一个重要活动上，不断思考别人是如何感受的，不断监控他们的情绪，以确保他们没事，他们玩得很开心，他们没有沮丧，以至于你甚至再也无法享受自己了。这里的决定性特征是所有权。你通常在无意识中认为他们的
emotional response is your burden to carry and your job to fix. I think it goes without. saying this can be incredibly draining because it places you in a constant state of hypervigilance. Your nervous system starts to anticipate their dysregulation before it happens, therefore disregulating you. You might catch yourself feeling guilty for things you didn't do or feeling responsible for problems you literally couldn't have prevented. And what's more, this habit can actually disempower the people around you because it assumes that they can't manage their emotions without your intervention. Sometimes what we're really doing is treating someone like a child.
情感反应是你要承担的负担和你要解决的工作。我认为不言而喻，这可能会令人难以置信地筋疲力尽，因为它使你处于持续的高度警惕状态。你的神经系统开始在他们的失调发生之前就进行预测，从而导致你失调。你可能会发现自己为没有做过的事情感到内疚，或者为你字面意义上无法阻止的问题感到负责。更重要的是，这个习惯实际上会剥夺你周围人的权力，因为它假设他们在没有你干预的情况下无法管理自己的情绪。有时我们真正做的是把某人当作孩子对待。
It's like we're putting ourselves in the position of a parent, even though they're an adult. They can experience hard things. They can endure hard things. They can learn from those hard things and still be okay. We often develop the belief that it is our responsibility to regulate others' emotions very, very young, very, very early on because of conditioning in childhood.
这就像把自己放在父母的位置上，尽管他们是成年人。他们可以经历艰难的事情。他们可以忍受艰难的事情。他们可以从这些艰难的事情中学习，并且仍然没事。我们经常形成这样一种信念，即调节他人情绪是我们的责任，非常非常年轻，非常非常早，因为童年时期的条件反射。
People, many of us, grew up in the environment, were emotional expressions, especially negative ones, like anger, sadness, or frustration. They were not just unpredictable, sometimes they were unsafe. When a caregiver's mood dictated the tone of the household, children learn to scan rapidly for emotional shifts and preemptively manage them in order to maintain a sense of safety. In such cases, you know, a child often internalize as a very distorted sense of control, basically along the lines of if I can keep them happy, everything will be okay. Over time, this morphs into a very deeply ingrained belief that other people's emotions
人们，我们中的许多人，在一个环境中长大，那里的情感表达，尤其是消极的表达，如愤怒、悲伤或沮丧。它们不仅不可预测，有时它们是不安全的。当照顾者的情绪决定了家庭的基调时，孩子们学会了迅速扫描情绪转变并进行先发制人的管理，以维持一种安全感。在这种情况下，你知道的，一个孩子通常会内化一种非常扭曲的控制感，基本上顺着“如果我能让他们开心，一切都会好起来的”的思路。随着时间的推移，这演变成一种根深蒂固的信念，即别人的情绪
are their personal responsibility. This conditioning often manifests itself later as drum roll please. People pleasing. People pleasing, a lot of people don't know this, is actually a coping mechanism. It's a coping mechanism rooted in a fear of rejection and rooted in a fear of disapproval. People pleasers often overextend themselves emotionally, not just to be liked. That's only one component of this, but to avoid the discomfort of someone else's negative reactions. According to psychologist Harriet B. Breaker, she's the author of The Disease to Please.
是他们的个人责任。这种条件反射后来通常表现为，请敲击鼓声。取悦他人。讨好他人，很多人不知道这一点，其实是一种应对机制。这是一种根植于对拒绝的恐惧和对不赞成的恐惧的应对机制。讨好者经常在情感上过度延伸自己，不仅仅是为了被喜欢。这只是其中的一个组成部分，而是为了避免别人消极反应带来的不适。根据心理学家哈里特·B·布雷克的说法，她是《取悦症》一书的作者。
This behavior stems from a need for external validation and also a subconscious belief that one's worth is tied to being agreeable, accommodating, and most importantly, conflict-free. When someone gets upset, the people please are, it's not just that they don't want to witness the emotion, it's that they absorb it and they believe it's their duty to fix it, even when they have absolutely no part in causing it. This self-imposed kind of responsibility becomes exhausting. It often reinforces as well a cycle of hidden self-neglect. Let's talk about gender. It's talk about gender when it comes to managing other people's emotions, because gender socialization definitely complicates this pattern. Women in particular are often raised to be caretakers, not just of others, but of their emotions. They are encouraged, even subliminally, to be empathetic, nurturing, to be very sensitive to other people's needs. Boys, on the other hand, are typically taught to suppress emotions or to handle them independently.
这种行为源于对外部验证的需求，以及潜意识中认为一个人的价值与随和、迁就、最重要的是没有冲突挂钩的信念。当某人生气时，讨好者，不仅仅是他们不想目睹这种情绪，而是他们吸收了它，他们相信修复它是他们的责任，即使他们完全没有参与导致这一切。这种自我强加的责任变得精疲力竭。它通常还会强化一个隐藏的自我忽视的循环。让我们谈谈性别。让我们谈谈在管理他人情绪方面的性别，因为性别社会化绝对使这种模式变得复杂。尤其是女性，往往被培养成照顾者，不仅照顾他人，还照顾他们的情绪。他们甚至在潜意识里受到鼓励，要富有同情心、有培育性、对别人的需求非常敏感。另一方面，男孩通常被教导压抑情绪或独立处理它们。
Both people lose in this situation. Both genders are losing. As a result, many women grow up with kind of an invisible curriculum that teaches them their job is to, move things over. It is to regulate tension. It's to serve as kind of emotional support systems. I think this disproportionate expectation, it's not an innate thing. We're not born with it. It's definitely cultural. And it's led to a phenomenon known in psychology and beyond as emotional labor where one person becomes the designated feeler, the designated fixer, especially in relationships, at the cost of their own mental and emotional well-being. They do more labor when it comes
在这场情况中，双方都输了。两性都在输。结果，许多女性长大后带着一种隐形的课程，教导她们的工作是，转移事情。它是调节紧张局势。它是作为一种情感支持系统。我认为这种不成比例的期望，这不是先天的事情。我们生来就没有。这绝对是文化上的。它导致了心理学及其他领域被称为情绪劳动的现象，即一个人成为指定的感受者，指定的修复者，特别是在关系中，以牺牲他们自己的心理和情感福祉为代价。当涉及到维持别人的感情和保护他们的感情时，他们付出更多的工作。
to holding up other people's feelings and protecting their feelings. Think at its core, believing we are responsible for other people's emotions sometimes reflects a lack of healthy emotional boundaries. And this is often shaped by trauma. It's shaped by unmet needs. It's shaped by the past. It's shaped by subconscious fears. From a psychological standpoint, this belief really blurs the lines between what we call enmeshment and empathy. Empathy, empathy, is great. Empathy allows us to feel with someone else. It allows us to see things from their perspective and be compassionate. Emmishment, on the other hand, traps us in feeling for them. It becomes hard to differentiate with enmeshment when their emotions end and ours begin. This is also very costly
我认为其核心是，相信我们对别人的情绪负有责任有时反映出缺乏健康的健康情感边界。这通常是由创伤塑造的。它由未满足的需求塑造。它由过去塑造。它由潜意识的恐惧塑造。从心理学的角度来看，这种信念真正模糊了我们所谓的融合与共情之间的界限。共情，共情，是伟大的。共情允许我们与别人一起感受。它让我们能够从他们的角度看待事物并富有同情心。另一方面，融合使我们陷入为他们感受的困境中。当他们的情绪结束而我们的情绪开始时，很难与融合区分开来。这也是非常昂贵的
to our relationships. I think that goes without saying. To us, managing other people's emotions might feel like devotion. It might feel like sacrifice and kindness. All things we were taught are very valuable to display in a relationship. But love doesn't require us to be emotional shock absorbers. Real intimacy doesn't thrive in a relationship where one person is always managing the other person. And so they end up feeling resentful and burnt out. And they end up feeling kind of like a bit of a quiet grief for what they're missing out on in a relationship. Ironically, I think it also stunts genuine closeness because you guys know this. true connection isn't built on emotional performance. It's not built on perfection. It's built on
对我们的关系而言。我认为这是不言而喻的。对我们来说，管理别人的情绪可能感觉像是一种奉献。它可能感觉像是牺牲和善良。所有这些我们被教导在关系中展示是非常有价值的事情。但爱并不要求我们成为情绪减震器。真正的亲密关系不会在一头总是管理另一头的关系中蓬勃发展。因此，他们最终会感到怨恨和筋疲力尽。他们最终会为他们在关系中错过的内容感到一种安静的悲伤。具有讽刺意味的是，我认为它也会阻碍真正的亲密感，因为你们都知道这一点。真正的联系不是建立在情感表现上的。它不是建立在完美之上的。它是建立在
real deep honesty and intimacy and hard moments and autonomy, but also on mutual recognition. Both people are able to come to the table with their baggage and you sort through it together rather than just one person taking over. Listen, I want to say it's not that you're being cruel, quite the opposite, and it's not like you can't help someone with what they're going through or help them with a bad day, what I'm saying is when this becomes your biggest and only priority, it can become harmful. Holding space for someone else's emotions without shrinking ourselves really starts with understanding that empathy and self-abandonment are not the same thing.
真实的深度诚实和亲密、艰难的时刻和自主权之上，同时也建立在相互认可的基础上。双方都能够带着他们的包袱来到桌前，你们一起解决它，而不是一个人接管。听着，我想说，这并不是说你很残忍，恰恰相反，这也不是说你不能在别人经历的事情上帮助他们或帮他们度过糟糕的一天，我想说的是，当这成为你最大也是唯一的优先事项时，它就会变得有害。在不缩小自我的情况下为别人的情绪留出空间，真正始于理解同理心和自我遗弃不是同一回事。
True empathy, the kind we really want to celebrate, means being with someone in their emotional experience, not absorbing it, not fixing it, not making yourself small so they can can be okay. It means saying, I see this, I see you, I hear you, I'm here, without saying I'm going to take this all away, without taking their pain on you as your own personal sacrifice. This requires emotional boundaries, it requires the ability to care without carrying, and just to listen, just listen and be present. A key part of this is also just checking in with your nervous system when you're supporting others, because often it is an instinct to jump right in and I want to fix everything, and then to see your own nervous system and your own stress response spike. So really ask
真正的同理心，我们真正想要庆祝的那种，意味着与某人一起体验他们的情感经历，而不是吸收它，不是修复它，不是让自己变得渺小以便他们可以好起来。这意味着说，我看到了这个，我看到了你，我听到了你，我在这里，而不是说我要把这一切都拿走，而不是把他们的痛苦当作你自己的个人牺牲。这需要情感边界，它需要关怀而不承载的能力，以及只是倾听，只是倾听并保持存在。这其中的一个关键部分也是在支持他人时检查你的神经系统，因为通常本能是直接跳进去，我想修复一切，然后看到你自己的神经系统和压力反应飙升。所以真的要问
yourself, am I grounded? Do I feel safe? Am I abandoning my own needs or values in this moment? Is this upsetting me such that I can't enjoy my own experiences? If the answer is yes, it's a sign you may be overextending and overcompensating. So in those moments, please remind yourself, their feelings are totally valid, but they are also not mine to fix. This person is fully capable of managing their own emotions with my help. I don't need to fix it. I just need to be there with them. It also means practicing honest communication, which I know can be so hard for those of us who are conflict-averse. I personally really struggle with this. I don't want to stir the pot. I don't want to make things more difficult, so I just ignore it altogether. But there are some phrases that you can practice,
你自己，我脚踏实地吗？我觉得安全吗？此刻我是否放弃了自己的需求或价值观？这是否让我心烦意乱，以至于我无法享受自己的经历？如果答案是肯定的，这是一个信号，表明你可能过度延伸和过度补偿。所以在那些时刻，请提醒自己，他们的感受完全有效，但它们也不是我去解决的。这个人完全有能力在我的帮助下管理自己的情绪。我不需要修理它。我只需要和他们在一起。这也意味着练习诚实的沟通，我知道对于我们这些厌恶冲突的人来说，这可能非常困难。我个人真的很挣扎。我不想挑起事端。我不想让事情变得更困难，所以我直接忽略了它。但有一些短语你可以练习，
you can bring into your vocabulary that can really help you out. You can say things like, I really want to be here for you, but I also need a moment to catch my breath. Or I care about how you're feeling and I want to support you, but I don't want to lose myself in the process. This kind of emotional honesty, it's really vulnerable, it's hard, but it also sets a powerful tone and boundary. I love you, but I'm not going to martyr myself for you. In fact, I think it also makes the bond between you stronger. If they're used to asking you for things all the time, this is you asking them for something. It levels out the playing field. Also, and I know it's going to feel strange doing this, but sometimes you just have to let them be angry and just to watch
你可以把它们带入你的词汇中，这真的可以对你有所帮助。你可以说这样的话，我真的很想为你在这里，但我需要一点时间喘口气。或者我关心你的感受，我想支持你，但我不想在这个过程中迷失自我。这种情感上的诚实，真的很脆弱，很难，但它也设定了强大的基调和界限。我爱你，但我不打算为你殉道。事实上，我认为这也使你们之间的纽带更强。如果他们习惯于一直向你索取东西，这是你在向他们索取东西。它拉平了竞争环境。此外，我知道这样做会感觉很奇怪，但有时你只能让他们生气，只是去观察
that feeling and let them be tired, let them be hungry, let them make mistakes, and then let them help themselves. If someone truly doesn't know how to self-regulate, you're not helping them any further by keeping them dependent on you. You think you're helping, you are hurting them if they genuinely don't have the skills to do this. I think what this mantra really invites us to do is just to examine the ways that we've internalized responsibility for other people's emotional states, and just to question, is that responsibility ever truly ours? It's not about indifference, it's about recognizing the limits of our role in someone else's inner world. We can't get into their brain and switch on different switches. We have to just sometimes view what's going on from the
那种感觉，让他们累，让他们饿，让他们犯错误，然后让他们自己帮助自己。如果某人真的不知道如何自我调节，你让他们依赖你，对他们没有任何帮助。你以为你在帮忙，如果你真的没有这样做的技能，你是在伤害他们。我认为这个曼陀罗真正邀请我们做的是只检查我们内化对其他人情绪状态责任的方式，并质疑，这种责任真的是我们的吗？这不是关于冷漠，而是关于认识到我们在别人内心世界中角色的局限性。我们不能进入他们的大脑并打开不同的开关。我们有时必须从
outside. Okay, we are going to take a short little break, but afterwards I'm going to share with you all how this to show up in my own life, especially recently. What I've learned, where I've struggled what I am still figuring out. Stay with us. Okay, now that we've looked at the meaning behind today's marcher. I'm not here to manage other people's emotions. It's time to get personal with you guys and share some of my own insights and reflections about this phrase. The place and the spaces where I feel most responsible for other people's emotions is in big group situations and I'm sure a lot of you can relate to this. When I have invited people to my house, when I am away on a trip with my girlfriends, when I'm hanging out with
外面。好了，我们要休息一会儿，但之后我会和大家分享这一切是如何出现在我自己的生活中的，尤其是最近。我学到了什么，我在哪里挣扎，我还在弄清楚什么。和我们在一起。好了，既然我们已经探讨了今天行进背后的意义。我不是来管理别人的情绪的，是时候和你们进行个人交流，分享一些我对这句话的见解和反思了。我感觉对别人的情绪负最大责任的地方和空间是在大型集体情况下，我相信你们很多人都能感同身受。当我邀请人到我家时，当我跟闺蜜去旅行时，当我跟
a big group of people. I always feel like I have to make sure everyone is having fun. Everyone is enjoying themselves. Not a single person can feel left out or feel bored or feel any sort of bad feeling. And if they do, like, that is terrible. I have failed as a host. I have failed as a friend. I don't really know when I first learned to do this. I just kind of know that I always have. Since I was very young, I think I saw discomfort, conflict, so-called negative emotions as kind of a threat, especially if someone else was feeling them. I thought that how they were feeling was a reflection of the emotional environment
一大群人一起闲逛时。我总是觉得我必须确保每个人都玩得开心。每个人都在享受自己。没有一个人可以感到被冷落或感到无聊，或感到任何不好的感觉。如果他们这样做了，那太可怕了。我作为主人失败了。我作为一个朋友失败了。我真的不知道我第一次学会这样做是什么时候。我只是觉得我一直都是这样。我很小的时候，我想我把不舒服、冲突、所谓的负面情绪视为一种威胁，尤其是当别人有这种感觉时。我以为他们的感受反映了情感环境
I was creating in that moment. What that doesn't recognize is that people are going to come into a situation with all kinds of emotional baggage, all kinds of stuff that's annoyed them and frustrated them from their day, all kind of stuff from their past. I feel like sometimes when we try to regulate other people's emotions, we kind of have this somewhat God complex that we are that significant in this person's life, that we could change their feelings more than the combination of everything else that's going on with them, which is not true. I was talking about where I first learned to do this, and I do think upon further reflection, probably in my case it has to do with being an eldest daughter,
我在那一刻创造的。没有认识到的是，人们会带着各种各样的情感包袱来到一个情境中，带着各种让他们烦恼和沮丧的事情从他们的一天中走过，带着他们过去的各种东西。我觉得有时当我们试图调节别人的情绪时，我们有点这种上帝情complex，即我们在这个人的生活中是如此重要，以至于我们可以改变他们的感受，超过他们身上发生的其他一切事情的组合，这不是真的。我一直在谈论我第一次学会这样做的地方，我确实认为经过进一步的反思，在我的情况下可能与身为长女有关，
Being an eldest daughter, I'm sure a lot of you, eldest daughters relate, it often really intensifies the pressure to manage other people's emotions because from an early age, a lot of us are cast into the role of emotional anchor, caretaker, third parent, whether explicitly or kind of asked or silently expected, we are often the ones who smooth over the conflict. We look after younger siblings. We support overwhelmed parents. and sometimes we do set the emotional tone for the household. So it's not just about a sense of responsibility.
作为一个长女，我相信你们中的许多人，长女们会有同感，这通常会加剧管理他人情绪的压力，因为从很小的时候起，我们许多人就被投进情感锚、照顾者、第三父母的角色中，无论是明确的还是被要求的或默契期待的，我们往往是抚平冲突的人。我们照顾年幼的弟弟妹妹。我们支持不堪重负的父母。有时我们确实为家庭设定了情感基调。所以这不仅仅是一种责任感。
It's about invisible labor, a form of, you know, emotional and relational work that a lot of women do that often goes unnoticed, but really shapes how we as eldest daughters come to see ourselves, that this role as caretaker is part of our identity, everything and everyone must be happy, safe together. This early emotional caregiving thing, as I said, does become part of our identity. we learn to anticipate the needs of others before their own needs even register. Sometimes we might actually enjoy it a little bit. I know this is going to sound strange, but we might really kind of revel in the fact that we are so
这是关于无形劳动的，一种（你知道的）许多女性所做的情感和关系工作，通常被忽视，但真正塑造了我们作为长女如何看待自己，这种作为照顾者的角色是我们身份的一部分，一切和每个人都必须快乐、安全地在一起。正如我所说，这种早期的情感关怀确实成为我们身份的一部分。我们学会了在别人的需求甚至没有注册之前就预测他们的需求。有时我们实际上可能会有点享受它。我知道这听起来很奇怪，但我们可能真的会沉迷于这样一个事实，即我们是如此
helpful and revel in the fact that we are so emotionally aware, because that's another component of this. People who feel like they have to manage other people's emotions are often incredibly emotionally intelligent and incredibly emotionally perceptive. that feels like a good thing because it is. That feels like a positive attribute and a positive quality. So it's hard to disentangle where that quality becomes quite negative and dangerous. Because if we've only grown up or taught ourselves to see this as a positive trait
乐于助人，并陶醉于我们对情感如此敏锐的事实，因为这是其中的另一个组成部分。那些觉得自己必须管理别人情绪的人往往具有令人难以置信的情商和令人难以置信的情感洞察力。这感觉像是一件好事，因为它确实如此。这感觉像是一个积极的属性和积极的品质。因此，很难厘清这种品质何时变得相当消极和危险。因为如果我们只在成长过程中或教导自己将此视为一个积极的特征
and as something that should be celebrated, recognizing the downsides of this is very hard because it means recognizing that perhaps not that we have flaws, but there are some downsides to our identity. As adults as well, a lot of eldest daughters, a lot of people who feel this position may find themselves in friendships or romantic relationships where, again, they just keep replaying and revising the same role, the role of fixer, peacemaker, therapist,
并且作为应该被庆祝的事情，认识到这一点的缺点是非常困难的，因为这意味着认识到也许不是我们有缺陷，而是我们的身份有一些缺点。作为成年人，许多长女，许多处于这个位置的人可能会发现自己处于友谊或恋爱关系中，他们再次不断重播和修改相同的角色，修复者、和平制造者、治疗师的角色，
at some point not because they want to anymore, but because again it feels natural because love to them has meant doing more, being more, absorbing more, managing more. The consequences of this have become a lot more apparent, the older I've become. Tell me if you relate to these feelings. I feel like I always feel stressed in social situations. I have less fun. I always feel like I'm the person having the least fun sometimes. I also feel resentment towards people that don't deserve it. I'm the one who has put them in the position where they have been forced to kind of rely on me. I'm the one who has tried to
在某个时刻，不再是因为他们还想这样做，而是因为再次觉得很自然，因为对他们来说，爱意味着付出更多，成为更多，吸收更多，管理更多。随着我年龄的增长，这带来的后果变得更加明显。告诉我你是否有同感。我觉得我在社交场合总是感到压力山大。我玩的更少。有时我总觉得自己是玩得最少的那个人。我对不值得的人也感到怨恨。我是那个把他们置于被迫依赖我的人。我是那个试图
control the emotional tone of the situation. It's my fault in a sense. Part of this also is that I avoid things that need to be said. I'm also a very sensitive person and if someone is even slightly upset or mad, I believe that they are upset or mad at me and that can be very devastating. So when there are things that actually need to be said and that would actually improve our friendship or our relationship, I just don't say them. I would prefer the lesser discomfort of being hypervigilant towards their emotional reactions than a full-blown conflict. Something I've learned probably in the last couple of years is that avoiding conflict
控制情境情感基调的人。从某种意义上说，这是我的错。这部分原因也是我避开了需要说的话。我也是一个非常敏感的人，如果有人哪怕有一点点沮丧或生气，我相信他们是对我沮丧或生气，这可能是毁灭性的。所以当有真正需要说的话，并且实际上会改善我们的友谊或关系时，我只是不说。比起彻底的冲突，我更喜欢对他们的情绪反应保持高度警惕带来的轻微不适。我可能在过去几年里学到的一件事是，逃避冲突
is a, sometimes a sign of emotional immaturity that you don't think you can handle big emotions so you avoid them. B, it's also 99 to 100% of the time going to make your relationships suffer more. When you just put something out on the table or put something out into the open and say, I'm upset about this, I'm scared about this, I'm angry about this, you resolve it so much quicker than if you let it sit in your stomach, in your brain, in your heart, in your mind for so much longer. Often managing other people's emotions also goes hand in hand with avoiding comfort. and with avoiding speaking up for yourself and just reflecting on your truth.
A，有时是情感不成熟的标志，你认为你处理不了大的情绪，所以你逃避它们。B，它也有99%到100%的时间会使你的关系遭受更多的痛苦。当你把某事摆在桌面上或坦诚布公地说出来，我对此感到沮丧，我对此感到害怕，我对此感到愤怒，你会比让它在你的胃里、在大脑里、在心里、在思想里呆更长时间解决得快得多。通常，管理别人的情绪也伴随着逃避舒适。以及逃避为你自己说话并反思你的真相。
So here is how I'm trying to change this, people pleasing, sense of ownership, emotional responsibility. Firstly, I'm just trying to notice when I'm doing it. The first step in anything is awareness. I've really been training myself just to pause when I feel that urge to like jump in, to just like pause when I feel like that tension in my chest, to pause when I feel like I need to start over explaining or when I feel overly responsible for how someone might react, I just ask myself, am I speaking or am I acting out of fear of how they feel rather than what's true for me? Does this person actually need my help right now? What am I trying to prove or say for this person by trying to help them? Is it empathy? Is it enmeshment? Just naming it and saying,
所以这就是我试图改变这一点的方式，讨好他人，所有权感，情感责任。首先，我只是试图在我这样做的时候注意到它。任何事情的第一步都是意识。当我感到那种想要跳进去的冲动时，我一直在训练自己暂停，当我感到胸口有那种紧张感时暂停，当我感到需要开始过度解释时暂停，或者当我对手可能如何反应感到过于负责时暂停，我只是问自己，我是因为害怕他们的感受而说话或行动，而不是因为对我是真实的吗？这个人现在真的需要我的帮助吗？我通过试图帮助这个人来试图证明什么或说什么？这是共情吗？这是融合吗？只是命名它并说，
I'm trying way too hard to manage their emotions right now and this is not going to be helpful. helps me step out of that autopilot kind of eldest daughter response. Secondly, I just have to remind myself, at the end of the day, I don't see my emotions as anyone else's responsibility. They don't see their emotions as my responsibility. Their emotions are not mine to fix. When someone is upset, I want to rush in, I want to soften it, I want to fix it, I want to make them feel better so I don't have to sit with the discomfort. I'm actually doing it for me. I'm the one who is uncomfortable. But when I gently tell myself, I can care without carrying, this person is fully capable of managing
我现在太努力地管理他们的情绪了，这不会有什么帮助。帮助我走出这种自动驾驶的长女反应。其次，我必须提醒自己，归根结底，我不认为自己的情绪是别人的责任。他们不认为自己的情绪是我的责任。他们的情绪不是我去解决的。当某人生气时，我想冲进去，我想软化它，我想解决它，我想让他们感觉更好，这样我就不必面对不适。我其实是在为自己做。我是那个不舒服的人。但当我温柔地告诉自己，我可以关怀而不承载，这个人完全有能力管理
this themselves. If I say to myself, I can help someone with the negative consequences, I can't help them with the cause or the origin, that small shift really changes everything. I also am trying, perhaps not always successfully, just to speak honestly, even when it's uncomfortable. Instead of managing their emotional responses, I'm trying and I'm practicing saying, what I really mean without cushioning it or diluting it to protect their feelings. That might sound like saying, I know this may disappoint you, but I need to say no. Or I can see you're upset and I just trust that you can handle that in your own way. I can see you need space to think about this. I can see you need space to manage this. I'm going to just step away for a second and let you do that. I don't need the answer right now.
这个自己。如果我对自己说，我可以帮助别人解决负面后果，我无法帮助他们解决原因或根源，那个小小的转变真的改变了一切。我也在努力，也许并不总能成功，只是诚实地说话，即使在不舒服的时候。我没有管理他们的情感反应，而是在尝试并练习说，我真正意思的话，没有垫层或稀释来保护他们的感受。这听起来可能像是说，我知道这可能会让你失望，但我需要拒绝。或者我可以看到你很心烦意乱，我只是相信你能以自己的方式处理好这件事。我可以看到你需要空间来思考这件事。我可以看到你需要空间来管理它。我只是要走开一会儿，让你去做。我现在不需要答案。
It's respect. I respect them. I respect me. The final step to this process. I respect. The final step to this process is just being okay with being uncomfortable, being okay with awkward silences, with someone frowning, with someone obviously being upset at you. Don't chase reassurance. Don't clean up their reaction. Breathe. Ground yourself. Remind yourself. I'm not doing anything wrong by letting them feel what they feel. Over time, I've noticed, you know, the world doesn't fall apart when I stop managing it. And neither do my relationships. They have gotten more honest. They've gotten more for feeling they've gotten healthier. I feel like I know people on a deeper level now because I'm seeing parts of them that previously maybe I avoided seeing or maybe I kind of incidentally like
这是尊重。我尊重他们。我尊重我。这个过程的最后一步。我尊重。这个过程的最后一步只是接受不舒服，接受尴尬的沉默，接受某人皱眉，接受某人明显对你生气。不要追逐安抚。不要收拾他们的反应。呼吸。让自己脚踏实地。提醒自己。我让他们感受他们所感受到的并没有做错任何事情。随着时间的推移，我注意到，你知道，当我停止管理时，世界并没有分崩离析。我的关系也没有。它们变得更诚实了。它们变得更有感觉，更健康了。我觉得我现在对人们有了更深层次的了解，因为我看到了他们以前可能避免看到的或者我可能顺便喜欢的部分
covered up for my own sake. It's a hard truth to really recognize about yourself. But once you get there, there's no looking back and also you'll just realize how much happier you are, how much easier and lighter your relationships feel. All right, now that we've unpacked what this mantra really means and how it has shown up for me, it's time to look at what we can do to bring this idea into action in our day-to-day lives. I'm going to share, of course, some journal prompts. You guys know I will always do that, but also our weekly challenge. So please, my lovely listeners, stick around for more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
为了我自己的缘故掩盖了。这是一个很难真正认清自己的真相。但一旦你到了那里，就没有回头路了，你也会意识到自己有多快乐，你的关系感觉多么轻松。好了，既然我们已经解开了这个曼陀罗的真正含义以及它如何为我出现，是时候看看我们可以做些什么来将这个想法付诸我们日常生活中的行动了。当然，我会分享一些日记提示。你们知道我总是会这样做的，还有我们的每周挑战。所以请，我可爱的听众们，在这短暂的休息之后留下来了解更多。2%。那是选择走楼梯的人的比例
I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world,
在也有自动扶梯可用的时候。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、健身和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等交谈，以超越主导健康行业的非实用和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me,
都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在I-HartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。名字是T-W-O-Percent。欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难学习》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太陷入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这件东西。我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做够了。
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活变得关乎赢输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现在世时做一个好人很重要。还是你是一个好人，因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同信任水平。我希望你真正做一个好人。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学习》中，我们就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你的免费I Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《艰难学习》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭斗争来证明真相。索因斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税金被用来做什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没有结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《受困之爱》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这新一季的《闺蜜》中……哦天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在乎。所以他们自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上拍了两次小金姆的胸部吗？或者当侃爷说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。听《女友说》节目。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击莉莉·金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟谋杀有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首往事》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集我们都会聚在这里，剖析当年发生了什么，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以聊聊当年的快克，但为了让大家清楚，我是说，马克，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。我开始发现这里面有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back. Let's take a few minutes just to really ground ourselves in this week's mantra. I'm not here to manage other people's emotions. The first thing I want to do is start with our deep thought of the day. You guys know in every mantra episode, I like to bring in some wisdom from, you know, a bunch of people who are smarter than me and who have probably thought about this a great
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。欢迎回来。让我们花几分钟时间，真正让自己沉浸在本周的正念箴言中。我来这里不是为了管理别人的情绪。我要做的第一件事，就是从我们今天的深度思考开始。大家知道，在每一期箴言节目中，我都喜欢引入一些智慧，来自那些比我更聪明的人，他们对这个问题的思考可能比我深入得多。
deal more than me. Today, our deep thought is coming from someone called Netra Clover to Wop. The greatest gift you can give someone is the space to deal with their own emotions. This quote, what I think is saying to me is, I believe you are capable of holding your own sadness, your own anger, your own uncertainty, even when it's hard. I have confidence in you. It's resisting the urge to rescue, to interrupt, to reframe their experience before they've had the chance to fully feel it.
今天我们的深度思考来自一个叫内特拉·克洛弗·托沃普（Netra Clover To Wop）的人。你能给别人最好的礼物，就是给他们空间去处理自己的情绪。这句话，我认为它对我说的是：我相信你有能力承受自己的悲伤、愤怒和不确定性，即使这很艰难。我对你有信心。这是在克制去拯救、去打断、去重新构建他们体验的冲动，在他们还没来得及完全感受到这些情绪之前。
And it's choosing to witness without interfering. That is a gift. That is a gift. you're helping them learn to swim. Yeah, maybe it's the hard way, but they're never going to learn if you don't take a step back. When we try to carry someone's emotions for them, we may be doing it out of care. In fact, I think 100% of the time we're doing it out of care, but we're also sending a quiet message. I don't think you can handle this. That's not a good feeling for someone else. Giving someone's space, however, is an act of deep respect. It honors the fact that growth often comes with really uncomfortable moments,
这是选择去见证而不去干涉。这是一份礼物。这是一份礼物。你在帮他们学会游泳。是的，也许方式有点艰难，但如果你不退后一步，他们永远也学不会。当我们试图替别人承载情绪时，我们可能是出于关心。事实上，我认为100%的情况下我们都是出于关心，但我们也同时在传达一个无声的信息：“我认为你应付不了这个。”这对别人来说可不是什么好感觉。然而，给予别人空间是一种高度尊重的表现。它尊重这样一个事实：成长往往伴随着真正让人不舒服的时刻，
that you have had to endure, moments of grappling that you have had to endure. But the emotional strength that you have has probably been built in that struggle because of it, not because of the avoidance of it. So it's not absence. You're not ignoring them, avoiding them, wanting them to be hurt. It's presence without the pressure. It's letting silence do its work, letting discomfort speak, letting them arrive at their own clarity, not the one that we hand them. That's really powerful. And again, that's a gift. With that in mind, let's sew down and just sit with this week's mantra. We're going to do our journal prompts. Now remember these journal prompts, they're just here to help you check in with where you are, what's coming up, where this mantra might be guiding you.
那些你不得不忍受的、充满挣扎的时刻。但你所拥有的情感力量，很可能就是在那种挣扎中建立起来的，正是因为经历了它，而不是因为逃避了它。所以这并不是缺席。你不是在忽视他们、避开他们，或者希望他们受到伤害。这是没有压力的陪伴。让沉默发挥作用，让不适感诉说，让他们自己得出清晰的结论，而不是我们塞给他们的结论。这真的很有力量。再说一次，这是一份礼物。带着这个心愿，让我们静下心来，细细体味本周的箴言。我们要开始写日记练习了。现在请记住，这些日记练习只是为了帮你核对一下自己目前的处境，看看有什么情绪涌现，或者这个箴言正引领你走向何方。
There are no wrong or right answers. And like I say, every single week, if journaling isn't your thing, I know for some people it doesn't really resonate with them. If you just don't have your journal nearby, that is totally okay. You can always pause this episode between questions just to take a quiet moment to reflect or just save these prompts for later. Typically, I share three questions a week, but this mantra felt very, very important. So I actually have four. Let's get into them. First, when do you tend to take on emotional responsibility that isn't yours? what do you fear might happen if you stop? Next, what childhood or early life dynamics shaped your instinct to manage other people's emotions? Can you trace this urge back to perhaps
没有标准答案或错误答案。就像我每周都会说的那样，如果写日记不是你的菜，我知道对有些人来说这可能没什么共鸣。如果你手头刚好没有日记本，那完全没关系。你随时可以在问题之间暂停本期节目，花点安静的时间反思，或者把这些提示留到以后再看。通常我每周会分享三个问题，但这个箴言感觉非常非常重要。所以我其实准备了四个。我们切入正题吧。首先，你倾向于在什么时候承担起不属于你的情感责任？如果你停下来，你担心会发生什么？接下来，什么样的童年或早年生活动力塑造了你“去管理他人情绪”的本能？你能把这种冲动追溯到你过去的某个情感根源吗？
an emotional origin in your past? Now, do you ever confuse maybe keeping the peace with being at peace? What is the difference between keeping the peace and being at peace for you? And finally, when you over-explain, when you apologize unnecessarily, or downplay your needs, who are you protecting and why? Now that you have made the space to reflect, let's give your mind a moment to rest. In just a second, you'll hear a music track. I just encourage you to take this opportunity to process this week's reflections in whatever ways feel right to you, no pressure, no expectations from me. And if this isn't something that you
那么，你有没有把“维持和平”和“内心平静”混淆过？对你来说，维持和平与内心平静的区别是什么？最后，当你过度解释、不必要地道歉或轻描淡写自己的需求时，你在保护谁？为什么？既然你已经腾出空间来进行反思，那就让你的大脑休息一会儿吧。一会儿你将听到一段音乐。我鼓励你借此机会，以任何你觉得合适的方式来处理本周的反思，不要有压力，也不要有来自我的期待。如果这并不是你擅长的事情，
connect with, that's totally okay. Just skip ahead about 30 seconds and we will be back. But as you settle in, please keep our mantra in mind with you today. I am not here to manage other people's emotions. As the music plays, just let this mantra shape your thoughts. Take the time to just connect with whatever it is bringing up for you in this moment. Beautiful. Now that you've had that very nice special moment just to reset and to ground yourself. Let's take that energy. Let's bring it into action with, of course, our weekly challenge. I'd love to hear how this goes for you. So if you want to reach out to me on Instagram at Mantra Open Mind, please share any follow-ups, whether this helped you in any way, what you learned, and also any questions or dilemmas you might have relating to this episode.
那也完全没关系。只要快进大约30秒，我们就会回来。但在你安顿下来的时候，请把今天的箴言铭记在心：我不是在管理别人的情绪。随着音乐响起，让这个箴言塑造你的思绪。花点时间，去连接它此时此刻为你带来的一切。太美妙了。既然你已经度过了非常美妙、特别的时刻来重置和沉淀自己。让我们带着这股能量。将它付诸行动，当然还有我们的每周挑战。我很想听听这对你的效果如何。所以如果你想在Instagram上联系我@Mantra Open Mind，请分享任何后续进展，这是否在某种程度上帮助了你，你学到了什么，以及任何与本期节目相关的疑问或两难境地。
or any other for our special bonus episodes which are available exclusively on Open Mind Plus. Okay, are you ready for this week's challenge? This week's challenge is the unfiltered no challenge. I want you to say no to something this week without over-explaining, without softening, without trying to manage or overthink how someone else might take it. Just a clear, respectful no, and then pause, then move on. It's going to feel uncomfortable. Just notice where you're feeling that in your body.
或者其他专门在Open Mind Plus上独家提供的特别加更节目。好了，你准备好迎接本周的挑战了吗？本周的挑战是“无条件拒绝”挑战。我希望你这周对某件事说不，不要过度解释，不要语气委婉，不要试图去管理或过度思考别人会怎么看。只需一个清晰、尊重的“不”，然后停顿，接着继续前进。这会让人感觉不舒服。只需留意你身体的哪个部位感受到了这种不适。
And notice when you find resolution from it. Because this emotion will pass. You can't live with discomfort for very long. It's not how your body is wired. So don't fear an emotion that really isn't going to be there for all too long. Good luck with your challenge. Let me know how it goes. I'm also going to do it.
并注意你何时从中找到了解决之道。因为这种情绪会过去的。你不可能长期生活在不适感中。你的身体不是那样设定的。所以不要害怕一种其实并不会持续太久的真实情绪。祝你的挑战顺利。让我知道进展如何。我也会去做的。
And I'll let you guys know how it goes for me as well. All right. As we wrap up this week's episode, I feel like it was a big one. I just want to share a few final thoughts about this mantra. I'm not here to manage other people's emotions. My final thought is this. When we try to manage other people's emotions, we are self-abandoning. And we are basically saying, your emotional state and your emotional reactions mean more than my own.
我也会让大家知道我的进展如何。好了。在我们结束本周的节目时，我觉得这是一期内容厚重的节目。我只想分享一些关于这个箴言的最后想法。我来这里不是为了管理别人的情绪。我的最终想法是：当我们试图管理别人的情绪时，我们在自我抛弃。我们基本上是在说：“你的情绪状态和情绪反应比我自己的更重要。”
Because when you try and help that person, hold them up, support them, often you're doing so, and you're creating your own discomfort. it and you're creating a situation that you're not enjoying and you don't feel good about it. Why are their emotions any more important than yours? How come you are fully responsible for your emotions but you can't recognize that other people can be fully responsible for theirs as well? This is not about ignoring people, neglecting people, not offering a helping hand when you see them struggling.
因为当你试图帮助那个人、支撑他们、支持他们时，通常你这样做是在给自己制造不适。这创造了一个你不喜欢、也感觉不爽的局面。为什么他们的情绪比你的更重要？为什么你可以完全对自己的情绪负责，却不能认识到别人也可以完全对他们自己的情绪负责？这不是要你去忽视别人、冷落别人，也不是在你看到他们挣扎时拒绝伸出援手。
It's about this not being the status quo for you. This not being the only way you can help. someone. If you take one thing away from this episode, let it be this, you are not here to regulate the emotional weather around you. You are here to live in alignment with your values, your truth, your peace that's going to make you a better friend, it's going to make your relationship stronger. I promise you that. Letting go of the need to manage other people's emotions, it's not selfish. It's actually very helpful for them as well to learn and to feel their own personal sense of emotional autonomy and personal responsibility.
这是关于不要让这成为你的常态。不要让这成为你帮助他人的唯一方式。如果你能从这期节目中带走一样东西，那就让它成为这个：你不是来调节你周边的情绪天气的。你是来践行你的价值观、你的真相、你的平静的，这会让你成为一个更好的朋友，会让你的关系更牢固。我向你保证。放手去管理别人情绪的需求，这并不是自私。事实上，这对他们自己来说也非常有益，能让他们学会并感受到自己个人的情感自主权和个人责任。
This week and beyond, celebrate that return, honor that return, and trust that when you do, what's real is going to remain and you're going to be okay. Thank you for joining Mantra, an exclusive Open Mind original powered by Pave Studios. At Open Mind, we value your support. So share your thoughts on social media. And remember to rate, review and follow Mantra to help others discover the share. show. For ad-free listening and early access to mantra with me, Gemma Spegg, we invite you to subscribe to Open Mind Plus on Apple Podcasts. I'll share another insightful and introspective
在本周及以后，庆祝这种回归，尊崇这种回归，并相信当你这样做时，真实的东西将会留下，而且你会过得很好。感谢加入由Pave Studios提供支持的Open Mind独家原创节目《箴言》（Mantra）。在Open Mind，我们珍视你的支持。请在社交媒体上分享你的想法。并记得给《箴言》打分、评论和关注，以帮助其他人发现这个节目。想要享受无广告收听以及与我（杰玛·斯佩格，Gemma Spegg）一起提前收听《箴言》，我们邀请你在Apple Podcasts上订阅Open Mind Plus。我将在下周一与你分享另一个深刻且具有内省意义的
mantra with you next Monday. Until then, keep showing up for yourself and your journey. I'm Gemma Speg. See you next week. Mantra is hosted by me, Gemma Speg. It is an open mind original powered by Payne Studios. This episode was brought to life by The Incredible. Mantra team, Max Cutler, Ron Shapiro, Stacey Warrinker, Sarah Camp, and Paul Lieberskin. Thank you for listening. To catch more episodes of Mantra, make sure to follow Mantra wherever you get your podcasts. There is also a link in today's show notes. Talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
箴言。在此之前，继续为自己和你的旅程挺身而出。我是杰玛·斯佩格。下周见。本期《箴言》由我杰玛·斯佩格主持。这是一档由Payne Studios提供支持的Open Mind原创节目。本期节目由优秀的《箴言》团队倾力打造，包括马克斯·卡特勒、罗恩·夏皮罗、斯黛西·沃林克、萨拉·坎普和保罗·利伯金。感谢收听。要收听更多《箴言》节目，请务必在任何你获取播客的地方关注《箴言》。今天的节目简介中也有一个链接。回头见。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the sign. of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《女朋友们》（The Girlfriends）。相信我，宝贝。在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回首往事》播客中。
1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what we. and trying to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
1979年，那对我是个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集我们都会邀请你来，剖析我们。并与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，试着理解我们是怎么熬过去的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations.
那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Care Games）主持的《艰难一课》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话。
that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app,
这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实都不安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，请在AHA广播应用上收听《艰难一课》，
Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular. or a test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父，但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你伪造了这个特定的。或两次检测，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探
to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and. Michael Rancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和。迈克尔·兰奇尼（Michael Rancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《被困的爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个I-Heart播客。保证由真人呈现。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。